j'ai entendu deux coups forts et je suis sorti avec
une lampe de poche
et quelqu'un avait tiré sur le panneau avec un
fusil de chasse
alors
[Musique]
c'est un endroit idéal pour élever votre famille,
mais
ce n'est pas un bon endroit pour peut-être exprimer une
opinion différente
sachez à qui vous pouvez parler
et à qui vous ne pouvez pas parler de
certaines
questions, en particulier des questions politiques en
général, les
gens croient que la présidence est
la présidence et vous n'en parlez pas mal
parce que c'est
ce que c'est et c'est qui a été élu
et si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec cela, alors
vous n'êtes pas américain
ou vous ne vivez pas le
rêve américain, je suppose que vous ne montrez pas votre
fierté américaine,
nous ne sommes pas nombreux à
rester
proches les uns des autres, je peux
vous dire que les membres de la famille se sont
inquiétés du fait que nous mettions la pancarte
je ne suis pas inquiet que
nous la montions parce que nous pensons
assez que le
pays va dans la mauvaise direction
je ne pense pas que le fascisme soit trop fort  d'un
mot à utiliser dans le cas de ce qui s'est
passé en Amérique,
nous étions dans la maison, il était environ
10 h 45 la nuit et nous avons entendu deux fortes
détonations et
je suis sorti avec une lampe de poche et
quelqu'un avait tiré sur le panneau avec un
fusil de chasse.
évidemment assez loin pour que
les plombs ne pénètrent pas dans le panneau
et par conséquent doivent prendre le panneau
tous les soirs maintenant
kaboom très fort ça m'a fait peur j'étais comme si
quelqu'un avait tiré un fusil de chasse là-bas, ils
sont venus sur notre propriété pour le faire c'est
ce qui a dérangé  moi
ils me rendent un peu nerveux parce que ce
sont des gens armés
il sait qu'il
va soulever une foule s'il vient
ici
et j'aimerais que biden le fasse parce que je pense qu'il le
ferait aussi mais je ne sais pas s'il
ne
pense pas que c'est nécessaire ou s'il ne l'a tout simplement pas fait
si
vous le saviez avec covid et tout n'a tout simplement
pas eu l'occasion d'aller aussi
loin, nous ne l'avons pas vu de
cette façon tellement